health officials here in new york city
and in los angeles are sounding the
alarm about a resurgence of the
coronavirus rising transmission rates in
los angeles could force a return to an
indoor mask mandate new york city's
health department is urging people to
wear masks in public indoor and indoor
settings and around large outdoor
gatherings this comes as cases and
hospitalizations are on the rise
nationwide here to discuss this latest
wave is cbs news medical contributor dr
david agus he's in los angeles david
good morning so it's called ba5 it's the
latest sub-variant that everyone seems
to be talking about what can you tell us
about the latest wave of infections
so this ba-5 is by far and i emphasize
by far the most infectious variant we've
seen and it's what we call immune
evasive which means even if you had
omicron a few weeks ago you can get this
new variant so the prior exposure
doesn't help you and the vaccines don't
help you from getting it
the vaccines help you from serious
illness and hospitalization especially
if you have a booster
but this is so infectious it's spreading
throughout the country over 90 percent
of places in the country have really
high transmissions rates so certainly
this is a new wave in a new era in the
cove
battle
and dr aegis as as we go are there added
health risks to getting coveted multiple
times are there greater risks of perhaps
long-term illness because of those
repeated illnesses
yeah what we're seeing is that every
time you get covered the chance for long
cover complications problems in the lung
uh psychological neurologic problems and
others go up
and so they build on each other the more
you get affected so certainly now where
a good portion of the country is being
exposed to ba5 we are worried again and
there's a new variant coming and it's in
india it took over bi5 literally in
several weeks called ba.2.75
and that will be our next wave here so
we're going to have these successive
waves we have to make sure we keep
vaccines and boosters up in this country
along those lines what is the latest in
terms of getting a vaccine or booster i
should even say that is linked directly
to ba5 or even this next variant
oh dana dana dana um
you know we will get
variant boosters in october um right now
they're not including ba4 ba-5 they're
the former omicron variants which still
give us more protection of ba four and
pi five than the original but right now
it's still too long a cycle when a new
variant comes to put it into a booster
we were told it would be six months
we're a year out now and we still don't
have them and so we need to build a
better faster process in the united
states to keep rolling out the new
boosters
you know i we we've said this before is
this just our new normal where we just
have to ride this wave of waves
yeah i see that in your eyes uh you know
yes this is our new normal and we're
going to keep we're going to live with
the virus we have backups we have
monoclonal antibodies we have paxlova
for people at high risk but we have to
keep them we're not doing well at
getting those boosters there are 40 000
hospitalizations now in the united
states and that is way too many
most are preventable with boosters in
these medicines and we have to use them
so we can continue to live with the
virus and ride these waves as you put it
so i guess the mask is coming back on
for good or at least for now dr david
agus thank you so much